Here's the first thing that might surprise
audiences about Hard Kill: The low-budget
action drama is low-key killing it with a
stronger-than-expected showing on Netflix.
Leave it to the streaming masses to show the
film critics of the world that they just don't
understand fun.
If you were given the basic plot summary –– a
hardened ex-special forces mercenary is hired
by a tech billionaire to save his kidnapped
daughter and safeguard a potentially world-shattering
piece of MacGuffin software –– which one
would you guess Bruce Willis was playing?
Okay, so he's not the kidnapped daughter,
but neither is he the mercenary in this instance.
That part goes to Jesse Metcalfe, 23 years
younger than Willis and more tolerant of the
hits and punishment that come with being an
action star.
That leaves Willis as Donovan Chalmers, corporate
CEO and scarf enthusiast, capable of running
a company that delves vaguely into AI and
quantum computing.
Does that sound complicated and perhaps a
little sci-fi?
It's really neither.
Hard Kill is about as uncomplicated an action
movie as you can find on Netflix, which is
why its chart-topping dominance comes as a
bit of a surprise.
In Hard Kill, written by Chris LaMont and
Joe Russo (not the Joe Russo you're thinking
of), Willis' Chalmers and Metcalfe's Derek
Miller team up to rescue his daughter and
the software from the hands of a terrorist
mastermind whose nom de guerre is "The Pardoner."
Willis is certainly the film's big above-the-title
star.
While there's no escaping the title intentionally
reminiscent of Die Hard, the movie is actually
it's own thing entirely.
Amazingly, this is Willis' third collaboration
with director Matt Eskandari over the last
two years, after 2019's Trauma Center and
2020's Survive the Night.
None of these cinematic outings have exactly
dazzled, though Survive the Night was arguably
the best received out of the trio.
Hard Kill presents a lot more of the same
from this thrifty and fecund partnership,
so if you liked the first two, chances are
good you'll find something to enjoy in the
third.
Metcalfe is a veteran of primetime soaps who's
carved out a second career as a low-budget
action and horror hero.
He played gardener-turned-lover John Rowland
on ABC's Lynchian suburban gothic Desperate
Housewives and grieving-parent-turned-vengeful-punisher
Craig Landry in 2010's The Tortured.
He starred as Christopher Ewing on the reboot
of Dallas and as Chase Carter in two movie
adaptations of the Dead Rising video game
series.
He was Trace Riley in Chesapeake Shores and
Luke Graves in Escape Plan 2: Hades.
You get the idea.
Along for the ride are Lala Kent as Chalmers'
kidnapped daughter, Eva, and WWE star Eva
Marie as Miller's team member Sasha Zindel.
Actors Texas Battle and Sergio Rizzuto return
from Trauma Center to play ally Nick Fox and
the villainous Pardoner, respectively.
Hard Kill is unlikely to win any critics'
choice awards this year.
It has a zero-percent rating from just 18
reviews on Rotten Tomatoes, with most of those
reporting that Willis' performance is somewhere
on a spectrum from exhausted to disdainful.
Frank Scheck of The Hollywood Reporter said,
"The production notes inform us that the unimaginatively
titled Hard Kill was filmed in a mere ten
days, making you wonder how they spent eight
of them."
The Guardian's Mike McCahill wrote in a one-star
review,
"Look beyond the lifelessly choreographed
shootouts,and you keep catching glimpses of
ghosts: those of American industry, yes, but
also those of the American action movie, once
manufactured with a skill, verve and wit wholly
absent from these painfully long 98 minutes
... Anyone hoping Bruce Willis might enjoy
a career renaissance after his rediscovery
in M. Night Shyamalan's Split and Glass: lower
those expectations now."
Of course, there's a certain niche a movie
like this is trying to hit, and close examination
for the purpose of writing a review isn't
quite it.
While the film has undoubtedly withered under
the critical gaze, it's actually above water
with the fans.
For what it's trying to be, Hard Kill appears
to be more successful than the scathing reviews
let on.
It holds an audience score of 67 percent on
Rotten Tomatoes, and judging by how it's doing
on Netflix, lots of people are willing to
at least give it a shot.
You could be the next convert.
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about your favorite
TV shows and movies are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don’t miss a single one.